I also Sean if you're listening Sean it's a specific apology to you because we we should have done better we should have done better. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 199 recorded on August 26, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about Stood Rotate. Okay, so let's talk about Rotate. Let's talk about Rotate. How do you implement Rotate? Are you kidding me?
Sean，如果你在听的话，我还要向你特别道歉，因为我们本可以做得更好，我们本可以做得更好。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 199 期，录制于 2024 年 8 月 26 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起聊聊 std::rotate。好的，那我们来谈谈 Rotate。我们来谈谈 Rotate。你如何实现 Rotate？你在开玩笑吗？
Have you not read Programming Pearls? Have you not watched one of my talks that mentions Programming Pearls? No. Really? Nope. this is famous man it's famous you connor i am completely shameless you will not make me feel guilty about not knowing something all right put your two hands up put your two hands up this is called what is it called the hand algorithm you gotta put your hands up like this all rightap the left one like that. And so I like you turned it 180 degrees. Do the same thing with the other one. And now do the same thing with the whole thing.
你没读过《编程珠玑》吗？你没看过我提到《编程珠玑》的演讲吗？没有。真的吗？没有。这很有名，伙计，这很有名。Connor，我完全不要脸，你不会让我因为不知道某件事而感到内疚的。好吧，把你的双手举起来，把你的双手举起来，这叫什么来着？手算法，你得像这样把手举起来，对，左手那样。然后我喜欢你把它转了 180 度。另一只手也做同样的事。现在对整个东西做同样的事。
What? It's three reverses, my guy. You implement rotate with three reverses. You've got your midpoint. Hang on. This hand thing you made. Whoa. I got one, two.
什么？这是三次反转，伙计。你用三次反转来实现 rotate。你有你的中点。等等。你做的这个手势。哇。我有一个，两个。
It's brilliant. Each time you flip your hand, that's the equivalent of reverse. So like say you got the numbers one to ten representing your ten fingers. You flip the first five. So now you've got five, four, three, two, one. You flip the next ones. So you've got ten, nine, eight, seven, six. And now you reverse the whole thing.
这太天才了。每次你翻转手，就相当于一次反转。所以，假设你有代表十根手指的数字 1 到 10。你翻转前五个。现在你有 5、4、3、2、1。你翻转剩下的。所以你有 10、9、8、7、6。现在你反转整个序列。
And what do you end up with? Beautiful. Beautiful, folks. We love it. 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. We love it, folks. My hands may be small, but the algorithm is beautiful. You're rotating at the middle point?
最后你得到了什么？太美了。太美了，伙计们。我们喜欢它。6、7、8、9、10、1、2、3、4、5。我们喜欢它，伙计们。我的手可能很小，但算法很美。你在中点处旋转吗？
Yeah, that's how you spend the 8. In this example, yeah. In this example, yeah. Or you can do it at the third point yeah that's how you spend the in this example yeah in this example yeah well you can do it at the third point or whatever but let's let's get the programming pearls uh programming pearls by john bentley we've all read it and by we i mean just me because bryce has not and everyone should read it it's fantastic book. And if we talk about the rotate. How do you implement reverse? Reverse? Just a bunch of swaps.
是的，这就是你如何花费 8。在这个例子中，是的。在这个例子中，是的。或者你可以在第三点处做，是的，这就是你如何花费……在这个例子中，是的，在这个例子中，是的，好吧，你可以在第三点处做，或者其他什么，但让我们……让我们看看《编程珠玑》，呃，John Bentley 的《编程珠玑》，我们都读过它，我说的“我们”只是指我，因为 Bryce 没读过，每个人都应该读它，这是一本很棒的书。如果我们谈论 rotate。你如何实现 reverse？Reverse？只是一堆交换。
Okay. Now walk me through it. Reverse? You've got a list of 10 numbers. Swap the first and last. Increment, decrement. Swap the second and second last. Increment, decrement.
好的。现在带我过一遍。Reverse？你有一个包含 10 个数字的列表。交换第一个和最后一个。递增，递减。交换第二个和倒数第二个。递增，递减。
All right. It's easy. Beautiful. So you take the midpoint right you you but that approach you just okay how do you what do you do if you have like just like a forward iterator if you just have a forward iterator well then that makes it a lot more complicated yeah this is why i ask these questions uh because, okay, so let's take a step back. The approach you just described, you've got a random access iterator to implement reverse.
好吧。这很简单。太美了。所以你取中点，对吧，你……但是你刚才描述的那个方法，好吧，如果你只有一个前向迭代器，你该怎么办？如果你只有一个前向迭代器，那就会复杂得多。是的，这就是我问这些问题的原因，呃，因为，好吧，让我们退一步。你刚才描述的方法，你有一个随机访问迭代器来实现 reverse。
You take, like, you know, the midpoint or you just have a way of being able to move from the back to the front. And then you start with the first and to the front and then you start it you start with the first and the last and then you swap them and then you increment the first and you decrement the last and then you keep swapping until first equals last correct or technically it's it might not be not equal to it might be a comparison yeah it's it's it's until yeah until you've's until yeah until you've reached the position until they collide or they go past each other yeah yeah um but uh okay so what is what is stood reverse require iterator categorize but that but that but for
你取，你知道，中点，或者你只是有一种能从后往前移动的方法。然后你从第一个开始，到前面，然后你从第一个和最后一个开始，然后你交换它们，然后你递增第一个，递减最后一个，然后你继续交换，直到第一个等于最后一个，对吧？或者从技术上讲，它可能不是不等于，它可能是一个比较，是的，它是……直到，是的，直到你到达那个位置，直到它们碰撞或越过彼此，是的，是的，嗯，但是，呃，好吧，那么 std::reverse 需要什么迭代器类别？但是，但是对于
that to work the reason i said forward for that to work you have to be able to take the last and then decrement it and to move backwards so reverse reverse requires bi-directional iterators and c++ and this is probably the reason why all right let me share my screen i will put a hopefully this doesn't crash anything folks i installed ubuntu 24.04 month ago or so and the windowing is terrible and the snapping every once in a while you try to maximize something and boom crashes your whole ui and then it forces you to log out so it could happen does it not screen window or tab can you see this actually it does not indicate to me at all if you're seeing this i can see it this is in the programming pearls book
那个要起作用，我之所以说前向，是因为要让它起作用，你必须能够取最后一个，然后递减它，向后移动。所以 reverse，reverse 需要双向迭代器，在 C++ 中，这可能就是原因。好吧，让我分享我的屏幕，我将放一个，希望这不会导致任何崩溃，伙计们，我一个月前左右安装了 Ubuntu 24.04，窗口管理很糟糕，而且捕捉功能，偶尔当你试图最大化某些东西时，砰，整个 UI 崩溃，然后它强迫你注销，所以这可能会发生。它没有显示屏幕、窗口或标签页，你真的能看到这个吗？实际上它根本没有向我指示你是否看到了这个，我能看到它，这是在《编程珠玑》书中
as we mentioned before by john bentley and it is the doug mcelroy hand waving description i was searching for the wrong stuff because i'm pretty sure you can find this image on the internet but i just went and got a version of the book online hopefully this Okay, so you reverse 0 to D minus 1, then you reverse D to N minus 1, then you reverse 0 to N minus 1. D being the point at which you want to rotate and N being the length of the list. And then it shows you with two hands, with five fingers, the exact thing that we just did. It is. Do we, do we, do we parallelize rotate? We do.
正如我们之前提到的，由 John Bentley 所著，这就是我一直在寻找的 Doug McIlroy 的手势描述，我搜索错了东西，因为我很确定你可以在互联网上找到这张图片，但我只是上网找了一个版本的书，希望这个……好的，所以你反转 0 到 D-1，然后你反转 D 到 N-1，然后你反转 0 到 N-1。D 是你想旋转的点，N 是列表的长度。然后它用两只手、五根手指展示了我们刚才做的完全相同的事情。确实是。我们，我们，我们并行化 rotate 吗？我们确实这样做。
That is a separate question, though. It uses this algorithm? That's actually a great question. Not reverse, but the question is, does thrust rotate use three different thrust reverses? That I would probably guess. I can't imagine that it does, because that would be three separate launches. I imagine it does something else weird. Let's find out.
不过，这是一个单独的问题。它使用这个算法吗？这实际上是一个很好的问题。不是 reverse，但问题是，thrust::rotate 是否使用三个不同的 thrust::reverse？我可能会猜是。我无法想象它会这样做，因为那将是三个单独的启动。我想它做了其他奇怪的事情。让我们找出答案。
All right. We are going, or Bryce is going to the Thrust implementation now, folks. That last episode, episode 198, probably only ended up being 10 minutes. I probably tightened it up real tight because we didn't talk about much. But now. 10 minutes? Yeah. Why would you post a 10-minute episode?
好的。我们要，或者 Bryce 现在要去查看 Thrust 的实现，伙计们。上一集，第 198 集，可能最终只有 10 分钟。我可能把它压缩得很紧，因为我们没聊太多。但现在。10 分钟？是的。你为什么要发布一集 10 分钟的节目？
Well, because we're bringing back algorithms and data structures content and we're just 10xing the rest. So we had the 10x most of episode 198, but 199 folks, this is the content that the listener has come for. We're talking about rotate. We're talking about reverses. We're talking about programming pearls and We're talking about programming pearls. And we're going to find out how we do this
嗯，因为我们带回了算法和数据结构的内容，我们只是把剩下的部分放大了 10 倍。所以我们把第 198 集的大部分内容放大了 10 倍，但第 199 集，伙计们，这就是听众想要的内容。我们在谈论 rotate。我们在谈论 reverse。我们在谈论《编程珠玑》，我们在谈论《编程珠玑》。我们将找出我们如何做到这一点
in parallel in Thrust. If this was a game show, we'd poll the audience and we'd say, what do you think, folks? Is it three reverses or is it a custom kernel? Where is rotate? Alright, he's taking too long. Do we have a rotate? We might not. Tragedy, folks. I'm at
在 Thrust 中并行实现。如果这是一个游戏节目，我们会对观众进行民意调查，我们会说，你们怎么看，伙计们？是三次反转还是自定义内核？Rotate 在哪里？好吧，他花的时间太长了。我们有 rotate 吗？我们可能没有。悲剧啊，伙计们。我在
the new CCCL Thl thrust documentation it's a beautiful site i didn't even try to look at the docs because those docs are a mess all right well i was about to say they're absolutely beautiful folks beautiful docs beautiful new docs i think bryce is just a little bitter because he did some work in a dark mode kind of thing and then they threw that out and they got beautiful new docs now folks they're beautiful i'm bitter because he did some work in a dark mode kind of thing and then they threw that out and they got beautiful new docs now folks they're beautiful I'm bitter because the search is not wonderful the search is fantastic once you learn
新的 CCCL Thl Thrust 文档，这是一个很棒的网站，我甚至没试着去看文档，因为那些文档一团糟。好吧，我正要说它们绝对很棒，伙计们，很棒的文档，很棒的新文档。我想 Bryce 只是有点苦涩，因为他在深色模式下做了一些工作，然后他们把它扔掉了，现在他们有了很棒的新文档，伙计们，它们很棒。我苦涩是因为他在深色模式下做了一些工作，然后他们把它扔掉了，现在他们有了很棒的新文档，伙计们，它们很棒。我苦涩是因为搜索功能不怎么样。一旦你学会了，搜索功能就太棒了
how to use it the team does great work and I shouldn't and there is no rotate folks that's why we don't like C++ anymore and I'm a full blown array language programmer. Let's, let's, let's, let's, gotta be a reverse though, right?
如何使用它，团队做得很好，我不应该……而且没有 rotate，伙计们，这就是为什么我们不再喜欢 C++ 了，我是一个彻头彻尾的数组语言程序员。让我们，让我们，让我们，让我们，一定有一个 reverse，对吧？
There's definitely a reverse. Yeah, I see a reverse. Why is there no rotate? Probably because, you know, they didn't know how to do it. They didn't know about Doug McElroy's algorithm. I don't accept that. What do you mean you don't accept that? I do not accept that as the reason that there's no rotate.
肯定有一个 reverse。是的，我看到了一个 reverse。为什么没有 rotate？可能是因为，你知道，他们不知道怎么做。他们不知道 Doug McIlroy 的算法。我不接受那个。你说的“你不接受那个”是什么意思？我不接受那是没有 rotate 的原因。
You know what language does have a rotate? APL and BQN. Beautiful, folks. Beautiful. Okay, let's look at the generic implementation of reverse. What is looking at the implementation of reverse going to tell
你知道什么语言有 rotate 吗？APL 和 BQN。太美了，伙计们。太美了。好的，让我们看看 reverse 的通用实现。看 reverse 的实现会告诉我们什么
us about? So it just does it in terms of swap ranges. So it does the midpoint thing, and then it does swap ranges. Okay. So what would a parallel rotate look like? So the naive version is gonna do three reverses yeah but the problem is we don't want to do three separate launches right so
关于它？所以它只是根据 swap_ranges 来做。所以它做了中点的事情，然后它做 swap_ranges。好的。那么并行 rotate 会是什么样子？所以朴素的版本会做三次反转，是的，但问题是我们不想做三次单独的启动，对吧？所以
we got to come up with something better um i mean you could do a you could do a rotate copy in one pass very easily obviously what would that look like you i mean you the way i would do it it could look like one of several ways but the way i would do it is i would combine a copy if with a permutation iterator where the permutation iterator just indexes into the correct element. And you could do that by wrapping the permutation. Actually, yeah, you could use that by basically doing a... They have it in Rapids, QDF. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我们必须想出更好的办法，嗯，我的意思是你可以很容易地一次性完成 rotate_copy，显然，那会是什么样子？你，我的意思是，我做它的方式，它可能有几种方式，但我做它的方式是，我会把 copy_if 和一个置换迭代器结合起来，其中置换迭代器只是索引到正确的元素。你可以通过包装置换来做到这一点。实际上，是的，你可以通过基本上做一个……他们在 Rapids, QDF 中有它。是的，是的，是的。
But you could do a counting iterator with a transform iterator and just do the modulus or some kind of integer arithmetic to do the indexing. It's a copy if, which boils down to a scan with some flags. Yeah, I buy that. I don't have the proof in front of me, but I buy that. That would have to be a rotate copy, though, not a rotate. The problem with the in-place one is that – so in your three reverses, the first two reverses can definitely happen in parallel. And you can come up with some sort of segmented from D to, you know, to the end of the thing.
但你可以用一个计数迭代器和一个转换迭代器，只做模运算或某种整数算术来进行索引。这是一个 copy_if，归结为一个带有标志的扫描。是的，我同意这一点。我手头没有证据，但我同意。那必须是 rotate_copy，而不是 rotate。原地算法的问题在于——所以在你的三次反转中，前两次反转绝对可以并行发生。你可以想出某种从 D 到，你知道，到事物末尾的分段。
Those are two completely different, you know, things. They're completely independent of each other. You're doing a similar operation. I suspect, I mean, at the very least, you could launch those two in parallel. I suspect you could do them in a single kernel. But then the problem is then you have to do this third reverse, which operates in the entire thing and sort of it is by construction
那些是两个完全不同的，你知道，东西。它们彼此完全独立。你在做类似的操作。我怀疑，至少，你可以并行启动那两个。我怀疑你可以在一个内核中完成它们。但问题是，然后你必须做这第三次反转，它作用于整个事物，并且从结构上讲
the first two reverses have to happen first. So maybe the answer is that the best you can do is two passes, but as anybody who's listened to this podcast faithfully knows, I find it hard to accept a multi-pass parallel algorithm. So there's got to be a better way. So there have to be other algorithms for rotate that are less efficient in the serial case but maybe are better in the parallel case so what else what else you got i'm trying to think of the word what do they say when they do like a
前两次反转必须先发生。所以也许答案是你能做的最好就是两遍，但正如任何忠实收听这个播客的人所知，我很难接受多遍并行算法。所以一定有更好的方法。所以一定有其他 rotate 算法，在串行情况下效率较低，但在并行情况下可能更好，所以还有什么，你还有什么？我正在努力想那个词，当他们做类似
over under hyped but it's not hype it's that reverse is a intellectually extremely simple algorithm but when it comes whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hang on a second hang on a second rotate reverse i said reverseate only requires forward iterators. So that means that the implementation, I think, is not just three reverses. So there must be some better algorithm than your three reverses. You don't know. You don't know. Come on.
过度炒作，但这不是炒作，而是 reverse 是一个智力上极其简单的算法，但当涉及到……哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，等等，等一下，等一下，rotate，reverse，我说过 reverse 只需要前向迭代器。所以这意味着实现，我认为，不仅仅是三次反转。所以一定有比你的三次反转更好的算法。你不知道。你不知道。得了吧。
You're supposed to be Mr. Rotate. You don't know any better way to do rotate than three reverses. You don't know, you don't, you don't know, come on, you're supposed to be Mr. Rotate. You don't know any better way to do, to do rotate than three reverses or a different way to do rotate than three reverses? Rotate algorithm. I'm gonna have Sean on here to come explain some, there's got to be something else. Parallel rotate. If I google for parallel rotate, I just get, you know, rotate along a parallel axis that doesn't help me at all you're being quiet are you cooking something now i'm just looking at the msvc stl implementation yeah yeah so so so i i looked at that too that those have um states so they're not immediately well that might explain why you can do it with forward iterators yeah let's go to cpp reference i want to like you ever watch that show who wants to be a millionaire
你应该是 Rotate 先生。你不知道比三次反转更好的 rotate 方法。你不知道，你不知道，你不知道，得了吧，你应该是 Rotate 先生。你不知道比三次反转更好的 rotate 方法，或者比三次反转做 rotate 的不同方法？Rotate 算法。我会让 Sean 来这里解释一些，一定有别的东西。并行 rotate。如果我谷歌搜索并行 rotate，我只会得到，你知道，沿平行轴旋转，那对我一点帮助都没有。你很安静，你在酝酿什么吗？现在我只是在看 MSVC STL 的实现，是的，是的，所以我，我也看了那个，那些有状态，所以它们不是立即……好吧，这可能解释了为什么你可以用前向迭代器来做它。是的，让我们去 cppreference，我想，你有没有看过那个节目《谁想成为百万富翁》
and it's like you have you have it was a show in like the late 90s the same age man we both know what that what that show is i'm explaining the listener. You'd have three – we have some Gen Z and Gen Ys on here. You'd have three lifelines that you could – it was a quiz show. You'd answer questions and you'd win progressively more money and you'd have three lifelines. And one of those lifelines was phone a friend. And I feel like I want to use my phone a friend um and uh i feel like i want to use my phone a friend i don't know who i'd phone but uh i guess sean i guess i would phone sean because he's mr rotate i called you mr rotate before but that's you're just you're just mr rotate fan boy yeah interestingly cpp reference And boy. Yeah. Interestingly, CPP reference says that the complexity is at most a distance first last swaps, which means that it's not the three reverse implementation.
那是一个 90 年代末的节目，伙计，我们都到了那个年纪，我们都知道那个节目是什么。我正在向听众解释。你有三个——我们这里有一些 Z 世代和 Y 世代。你有三个生命线，你可以——那是一个问答节目。你回答问题，你会赢得越来越多的钱，你有三个生命线。其中一个生命线是打电话给朋友。我觉得我想用我的打电话给朋友，嗯，呃，我觉得我想用我的打电话给朋友，我不知道我会打给谁，但呃，我想是 Sean，我想我会打给 Sean，因为他是 Rotate 先生。我之前叫你 Rotate 先生，但那是，你只是，你只是 Rotate 粉丝男孩。是的，有趣的是，cppreference 和男孩。是的，有趣的是，cppreference 说复杂度最多是 distance(first, last) 次交换，这意味着它不是三次反转的实现。
Rotate. Yeah. Yeah. We've established it. So what's the complexity of the three reverses? It's two and. Oh, it's like. Yeah, it's two and.
Rotate。是的。是的。我们已经确定了。那么三次反转的复杂度是多少？是 2N。哦，它是。是的，它是 2N。
Oh, that's awful. Get that. Get that nonsense out of here why is there not like a wikipedia page for the rotated algorithm i'm sharing my screen again folks because i you know what i was thinking i looked this up once i looked this up once you tell me what you see here buddy you tell me what you see here yeah yeah so they do the three reverses if they can yeah and they fall back to doing the stateful thing otherwise so is this does this mean it's not i mean cpp reference could be wrong in saying that um well okay let's let's let's stop reading cpp reference let's go read the standard find out whether these people are compliant yeah so i was gonna say oh this this episode this
哦，那太糟糕了。把那个，把那个废话拿走。为什么没有像 rotate 算法的维基百科页面？我再次分享我的屏幕，伙计们，因为我，你知道我在想什么，我查过一次，我查过一次。你告诉我你在这里看到了什么，伙计，你告诉我你在这里看到了什么。是的，是的，所以如果可以的话，他们确实做了三次反转，是的，否则他们会退回到做有状态的事情。所以这是否意味着它不是，我的意思是 cppreference 可能是错的，说……嗯，好吧，让我们，让我们停止阅读 cppreference，让我们去读标准，找出这些人是否合规。是的，所以我正要说，哦，这一集，这一集
episode might end with us filing some bugs. I'm not filing any bugs, but you can go ahead and... Yeah, at most last minus first swaps, the standard says. So yeah, this code, we will link this code. It's Microsoft STL slash a bunch of stuff slash slash inc, slash xutility. And it says, if constexpr is cpp17 random access iterator. I've elaborated a bit. That's not exactly how it reads.
可能以我们提交一些错误报告而告终。我没有提交任何错误报告，但你可以继续……是的，最多 last - first 次交换，标准是这样说的。所以是的，这段代码，我们将链接这段代码。它是 Microsoft STL / 一堆东西 / inc / xutility。它说，if constexpr 是 cpp17 随机访问迭代器。我稍微阐述了一下。它读起来不完全是那样。
And then it's got three calls to reverse. Then it says, else if constexpr is cpp bidirectional iterator. It's got the same thing except the auto temporary reverse until sentinel unchecked call and then otherwise it's got an else case where it does does a bunch of you know uh stateful stuff and a couple iterators uh with a do while loop followed by a while loop you don't see that every day folks okay so i'm filing uh i'm i'm getting we're getting the bottom of this here what do you find what are you filing i want to know why they're not following the standard and also is there actually a way to do a rotate i don't think that well to do a rotate in with last minus first swaps? Yeah, there is.
然后它有三次对 reverse 的调用。然后它说，else if constexpr 是 cpp 双向迭代器。它有同样的东西，除了 auto temporary reverse until sentinel unchecked 调用，然后否则它有一个 else 情况，它做了一堆，你知道，呃，有状态的事情和几个迭代器，呃，用一个 do-while 循环，后面跟着一个 while 循环，你不会每天都看到那个，伙计们。好的，所以我正在提交，呃，我正在，我们正在查明真相。你在提交什么？我想知道为什么他们不遵循标准，还有，实际上有没有一种方法可以做 rotate，我不认为，好吧，用 last - first 次交换来做 rotate？是的，有。
There's the way, the stateful way, right? Well, so say you've got 10 integers and you want to do a three rotate, meaning, and it's just an iota sequence. So it's one to 10 and you want to put one, two, three at the back. So that's a three rotate. The first thing you could do is just swap the first three with the last three and then you end up with the sequence assuming that it's one to ten so there's no zero so we're one indexed here you're going to end up with uh eight nine ten at the beginning then four five six seven one two
有那种有状态的方法，对吧？好吧，所以假设你有 10 个整数，你想做一个 3-rotate，意思是，它只是一个 iota 序列。所以它是 1 到 10，你想把 1、2、3 放到后面。所以那是一个 3-rotate。你可以做的第一件事就是交换前三个和最后三个，然后你最终得到序列，假设它是 1 到 10，所以没有 0，所以我们这里是 1 索引的，你最终会得到，呃，8、9、10 在开头，然后 4、5、6、7、1、2
three and so then you've only done whatever uh in this case, three out of your 10 possible swaps. So the question is, can you turn the 8, 9, 10, 4, 5, 6, 7 into 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 in seven swaps? And if you use four swaps to get the 4, 5, 6, 7 to the front, what do you end up with? You end up with, so I think it actually is possible. You end up with four, five, six, seven. We don't have to file a bug against the standard, just against the implementation. Yeah. Four, five, six, seven. And then the eight, nine, 10 is going to end up a little bit jumbled. But the point being is that like whatever order the eight, 9, 10 is, you've got three swaps left to get three values into their correct positions. And you won't need all of them because you really only need.
3，所以你只做了，无论什么，呃，在这种情况下，你 10 次可能交换中的 3 次。所以问题是，你能用 7 次交换把 8、9、10、4、5、6、7 变成 4、5、6、7、8、9、10 吗？如果你用 4 次交换把 4、5、6、7 放到前面，你最终会得到什么？你最终会得到，所以我认为这实际上是可能的。你最终会得到 4、5、6、7。我们不必针对标准提交错误报告，只是针对实现。是的。4、5、6、7。然后 8、9、10 会变得有点混乱。但重点是，就像 8、9、10 是什么顺序一样，你还剩下 3 次交换来把 3 个值放到它们正确的位置。你不需要全部，因为你真的只需要。
Right, so it can be done. You need like maximum two swaps of those three. And it'll vary depending on the rotate that you're doing. So it definitely can be done. Just not this way is that so alak dot alak dot rotate paragraph four states that the complexity is at most uh last minus first uh swaps uh but this three reverses approach is... If you have a forward iterator, though...
对，所以是可以做到的。你需要那三个中的最多两次交换。而且它会根据你正在做的 rotate 而有所不同。所以它绝对是可以做到的。只是不是这种方式，是吗？所以 alak.rotate 第 4 段指出复杂度最多是 last - first 次交换，但这种三次反转的方法是……如果你有一个前向迭代器，虽然……
Can you not do better with a forward iterator? No, I was going to say, does that kind of algorithm work with the forward iterator? Let's actually read through what this says. For the three reverses, is it exactly two N swaps? Oh, wait. I don't, we're, man, there's a few listeners that are upset. How many swaps does reverse take?
你不能用前向迭代器做得更好吗？不，我正要说，那种算法对前向迭代器有效吗？让我们实际读一下它说了什么。对于三次反转，它正好是 2N 次交换吗？哦，等等。我不，我们是，伙计，有几个听众很生气。Reverse 需要多少次交换？
We're idiots. Oh, we are idiots. Takes N over two. Takes N over two. Yes, we are idiots. We are idiots. We apologize to the listener that's been listening screaming into their headphones you know what the funny thing is the funny thing is connor what's the funny thing
我们是白痴。哦，我们是白痴。需要 N/2 次。需要 N/2 次。是的，我们是白痴。我们是白痴。我们向一直在耳机里尖叫的听众道歉。你知道有趣的事情是什么吗？有趣的事情是，Connor，有趣的事情是什么？
we like at the front end of this i asked how did we how do we implement reverse and we it's not it's not like we didn't think about this we literally talked about how you implement reverse and we talked about oh yeah it's like you take the midpoint and then like you swap the things up to the midpoint yeah this is the swap the things up to the midpoint. Yeah. This is the problem though. I almost filed the bug report. I almost looked like a complete ass. That's the thing though is in school, they teach you that the coefficient doesn't matter
我们，就像在这一集的开头，我问我们如何实现 reverse，我们，这不是，不是说我们没想过这个，我们确实讨论了如何实现 reverse，我们讨论了，哦，是的，就像你取中点，然后就像你交换中点之前的东西，是的，这就是交换中点之前的东西。是的。但这确实是个问题。我差点提交了错误报告。我差点看起来像个彻头彻尾的蠢货。这就是问题所在，在学校里，他们教你系数不重要
when it comes to time complexity. But this is, and so your brain is a lot of the times, or at least my brain shaves that. But the standard in this case, the standard in this case is not giving a time, is not giving a is not giving a like right they're talking about a number of swaps it's it's it's saying exact yeah but the promise it will be but that's the problem is that like we have i have a mental model that that thinks in terms of linear quadratic linear rhythmic and then whenever there is like a it's technically half linear right it's half O of N, but like you ignore that half.
当涉及到时间复杂度时。但这是，所以你的大脑很多时候，或者至少我的大脑会削减它。但标准在这种情况下，标准在这种情况下没有给出时间，没有给出，没有给出，就像，对，他们谈论的是交换次数，它说的是精确的，是的，但承诺它会是，但这就是问题所在，就像我们有，我有一个心理模型，以线性、二次、线性对数来思考，然后每当有类似，它在技术上是半线性的，对吧？它是半 O(N)，但就像你忽略了那一半。
But in this case, if we had paid attention to it, we would have realized that the three reverses, when you've got two partial reverses that equal a full reverse followed by a full reverse is ultimately that number of swaps. The first two reverses, each one of those is a fourth of your swaps. I also, Sean, if you're listening, Sean, it's a specific apology to you because we should have done better. We should have done better. But anyways, let me explain for the listener.
但在这种情况下，如果我们注意到了，我们就会意识到三次反转，当你有两个部分反转等于一个完全反转，后面跟着一个完全反转时，最终就是那个交换次数。前两次反转，每一次都是你交换次数的四分之一。Sean，如果你在听的话，Sean，我还要向你特别道歉，因为我们本可以做得更好。我们本可以做得更好。但无论如何，让我为听众解释一下。
It may not be fine. So the first two reverses each operate on half of the input. And so each one of those reverses does a fourth of the swaps. And then the – It's incorrect to say half they it works on a uh you know one minus percentage and then the other one does the other so technically you can do a zero rotate which is just a reverse yeah then then the then the the second or then the third reverse the of the whole thing does the other roughly half swaps. Yes. And I said, well.
它可能并不好。所以前两次反转各自作用于输入的一半。所以每一次反转都做了四分之一的交换。然后——说一半是不正确的，它作用于一个，你知道，1 减去百分比，然后另一个做剩下的，所以从技术上讲，你可以做一个 0-rotate，这只是一个 reverse，是的，然后，然后第三次反转，整个序列的反转做了剩下的，大约一半的交换。是的，我说，好吧。
So I'm going to show you how close I was to filing this bug report. And just to correct what I said. This is how close I've written the text. All I had to do was put in the title. Yes, he is very close to filing the bug. But yes, when I said zero rotate equals reverse, it means that the first half of the rotate algorithm would be reverse. Technically, a zero rotate is a no op, just so that we're not getting, we don't have listeners once again yelling it into their.
所以我将向你展示我离提交这个错误报告有多近。为了纠正我所说的。这是我写的内容，离得有多近。我所要做的就是填上标题。是的，他非常接近提交错误报告。但是的，当我说 0-rotate 等于 reverse 时，这意味着 rotate 算法的前半部分将是 reverse。从技术上讲，0-rotate 是一个空操作，只是为了让我们不被，我们不会再次让听众对着他们的……大喊大叫。
So can we do a segmented reverse? And by that, I mean, can we launch a reverse kernel where we say, here's two different ranges, reverse both of them? Because that is what essentially we would need to get from three passes down to two passes. And admittedly, you could also just launch the two independent reverses in parallel but if you didn't want to do that if you wanted to launch one big single pass as you do when you're gonna gpu matt rhymed i appreciate that um can that be done is this a scan well i was thinking that you could do something similar to unique by key but then i remember that actually because like what you what you want is a reverse by key, similar to a reduced by key, but the reduced is a reduction. So in Thrust, the way reverse gets implemented is you find the midpoint, and you just assume random access.
所以我们可以做一个分段 reverse 吗？我的意思是，我们可以启动一个 reverse 内核，我们说，这里有两个不同的范围，反转它们两个？因为这本质上是我们从三遍减少到两遍所需要的。而且不可否认，你也可以只并行启动两个独立的 reverse，但如果你不想那样做，如果你想启动一个大的单遍，就像你在 GPU 上做的那样，Matt Rhymed，我很感激这一点，嗯，这能做到吗？这是一个扫描吗？我当时在想，你可以做一些类似于 unique_by_key 的事情，但我记得实际上，因为就像你想要的是 reverse_by_key，类似于 reduce_by_key，但 reduce 是一个归约。所以，在 Thrust 中，reverse 的实现方式是你找到中点，然后你只假设随机访问。
So you find the midpoint, and then you do swap ranges from first to mid, and then with the reverse iterator to last. So what is swap ranges? I don't even know where that is. Oh, no, there it is. Okay. I think that one's pretty simple. Yeah, it's just a parallel four. So I think that since reverse ends up being implemented with a parallel four, which has no communication, I think any way of combining, any way of implementing a segmented reverse is going to be worse.
所以你找到中点，然后你从 first 到 mid 做 swap_ranges，然后用反向迭代器到 last。那么什么是 swap_ranges？我甚至不知道那在哪里。哦，不，它在那里。好的。我认为那个很简单。是的，它只是一个并行 for。所以我认为，既然 reverse 最终是用一个没有通信的并行 for 实现的，我认为任何组合，任何实现分段 reverse 的方式都会更糟。
Because implementing a segmented reverse, you're going to have to know when you've reached the end of one of those segments. And that means you're going to need communication. And so that's going to be strictly worse than an embarrassingly parallel approach. And so I think we've finally hit upon an example on this podcast of an algorithm where more passes is going to be better. Specifically, I think the best approach for this is going to be to launch, assuming that there's not some other completely different algorithm, the best approach to implementing the three reverse or a reverse-based rotate is going to be to launch the two
因为实现分段 reverse，你必须知道什么时候到达了那些段的末尾。这意味着你需要通信。所以这会严格地比尴尬的并行方法更糟。所以我认为我们终于在这个播客上找到了一个算法的例子，其中更多的遍数会更好。具体来说，我认为最好的方法是启动，假设没有其他完全不同的算法，实现三次反转或基于 reverse 的 rotate 的最好方法是启动两个
initial reverses, the two reverses of half the sequence in parallel um and then to launch the third reverses like as a dependency that depends upon the first two unless unless he said unless there's a way to do this all in a single pass in which case the benefit of keeping everything in memory may be worth it. But actually, yeah, so if you could do this in a way where you didn't have to go back to global memory, where you load and store each thing from global memory a single time, that would, I think, be better than the three reverses approach. So I think there's a better algorithm out here. Well, we will leave that to a future episode because we have hit the limit.
初始反转，两个半序列的反转，并行，嗯，然后启动第三次反转，作为依赖于前两次的依赖项，除非，除非他说，除非有一种方法可以在单遍中完成所有这些，在这种情况下，保持所有内容在内存中的好处可能值得。但实际上，是的，所以如果你能以一种不需要回到全局内存的方式来做，你从全局内存加载和存储每一件事一次，那我认为会比三次反转的方法更好。所以我认为这里有一个更好的算法。好吧，我们将把它留到未来的一集，因为我们已经达到了极限。
Which brings us to episode 200, folks. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这把我们带到了第 200 集，伙计们。请务必在你的播客应用程序或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上查看这些节目笔记，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。